mit fast 300 stundenkilometern rast die
im märz vergangenen jahres über die
autobahn als es zu dem tödlichen unfall
kam mit seinem 570 ps sportwagen geriet
an einen unfall seine 18 jährige
beifahrerin gap starb dabei und heute
hat der prozess angefangen mir nun
zugeschaltet von dort am amtsgericht in
essen ist dirk dekker wird heute der
erste prozesstag um 39 ging es los was
ist bisher passiert ja zuerst wurde die
anklage verlesen dass die ist wegen
fahrlässiger tötung angeklagt
sollen im märz vergangenen jahres sollen
sich die clique unter anderem china
darunter in einem mcdonald's hier in
essen getroffen haben
was ist dann mit seinem mclaren nachdem
in china wohl gefragt hatte ob sie damit
fahren darf auf die autobahn aufgefahren
an der abfahrt oder auffahrt in richtung
düsseldorf gefahren dann nach wenigen
kilometern ist wohl auf dieser fahrbahn
eine leichte bodenwellen der gutachter
sagte dass die 40 meter tief sein diese
bodenwelle 40 bis 50 millimeter tief hat
der wagen oder arzt lasst die dann wohl
die kontrolle verloren und nach 138
metern in die mittelleitplanke
zuerst gekracht dann in die rechte
leitplanke dort hat sich der mclaren
dann überschlagen ist in einen abhang
gegen einen baum geprallt
dabei wurde die nato laut anklage aus
dem auto geschleudert rechte arm oder
abgerissen
mit schwersten schädelverletzungen an
denen sie noch am unfallort verstarb
der unfallfahrer selbst kam mit leichten
verletzungen davon liest aus seinen
anwalt hier heute erstmal eine erklärung
verlesen
wo er den unfall als solches einräumt
aber nicht alles zugibt was die anklage
mir vorwirft
wir hatten kurz gelegenheit mit der
mutter zu sprechen die sowohl die mutter
claudia also auch der vater der
verstorbenen verfolgen den prozess als
nebenkläger an sie hat der angeklagte
auch ein kurzes wort gerichtet
entschuldigung gebeten dass es ihm leid
unendlich leid täte aber eher dadurch
natürlich dienen nicht wiederholen kann
mutter bemängelt dass als ja einfach
taktik der verteidigung und nimmt diese
entschuldigungen auch nicht recht an sie
ist es ist der verlust ihrer tochter
allgegenwärtig speed jederzeit sehr
schnell wir uns diese uns selber kurz
vorher noch sagte